bon mes chers amis d'abord le patron
dira mieux que moi tout à leur merci à
vous toutes et à vous tous de vous être
déplacés on sait bien qu'à un samedi
matin
ça n'est pas simple mais ça fait
toujours plaisir et au président et ses
hauts responsables de du mouvement de
voir que finalement même un samedi matin
vous êtes nombreux vous êtes nombreux et
mobiliser ce qui prouve quand même que
quand on lit la presse c'est qu'on dit
plus personne ne s'intéresse à la
politique
le monde politique est discréditée
plus personne ne veut en réalité
s'engager maintenant tous les mêmes tous
pareils il n'y a pas d'avenir
y'a plus rien dans ce pays bas en vrai
c'est faux vous êtes la démonstration
vivante que tout ça n'a pas de sens vous
êtes la démonstration de ce que je vois
moi dans mon département des
hauts-de-seine où nous avons la chance
ou la malchance d'avoir trois élections
municipales partielles
j'espère qu'on gagnera les 3es au
nicolas sarkozy est venu faire deux
meetings archibondé pourquoi mais parce
que c'est comme ça depuis trois ans y'a
pas à dire vous êtes heureux
bon d'accord c'est facile et ça marche à
tous les coups
d'accord allez savez moi j'ai des
souvenirs parce que j'ai fait avec lydia
avec lydia guirous si si notre nouvelle
porte parole cowboys applaudir je fais
naturellement comme beaucoup la campagne
de 2012 et on avait un sentiment assez
partagés de se dire on entraîne on
mobilise on met en avant un certain
nombre de thèmes et de l'autre côté il
ya tellement de fausses affirmations
tellement de calomnies tellement de
mensonges tellement de promesses
tellement d'engagement dont on savait
parfaitement qu'il ne serait pas tenue
la déception est venue très vite
pratiquement françois hollande et
monsieur 20% d'opinions favorables
depuis deux ans c'est à dire que depuis
deux ans il ne remonte jamais c'est
quand même un président absolument
invraisemblable le type il a tout vu
à côté bernadette soubirous elle manque
de vision il nous est dit il nous a dit
début 2013
je vois l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage
bon d'accord deux ans et demi après
toujours rien le chômage continue
d'augmenter et alors les ministres
successifs se croit obligé de dire c'est
pour la fin de l'année
le problème c'est qu'il faudrait qu'ils
arrêtent de dire laquelle
comme ça on verra bien quand ça se
produit alors en 2014 fin 2013 début
président la république nous a dit je
sens les prémices des débuts de la
croissance personne n'a rien vu en 2014
et on nous annonce que 2015 on peut
faire peut-être peut-être 1% ce qui ne
créera toujours pas d'emplois ce qui ne
créera toujours pas de richesses mais en
tout cas il l'a vu
il nous a dit quand même l'axé franco
allemand
c'est moi moi moi un mois lui et au fur
et à mesure des discussions européennes
on s'est rendu compte que madame merkel
parlé avec monsieur poutine parlait avec
monsieur obama parle avec monsieur
cameron et qu'en réalité la place le
rôle
la présence de la france était de plus
en plus inexistantes et en réalité
qu'est ce qu'on voit depuis trois ans
une augmentation du chômage 1 million de
chômeurs supplémentaires
un rôle place de la france totalement
discréditée on ne compte plus on ne
participe plus aux négociations par
exemple avec l'iran sur le nucléaire
on ne sait plus quoi faire de nos
mistral par rapport à la russie
on ne sait plus ce qu'on doit dire en
ukraine on ne sait plus d'ailleurs ce
qu'on doit dire à qui que ce soit
puisque par définition on dit tout et
ses ministres disent inverse
on a une situation où en réalité
l'économie va mal on dit aux entreprises
tout et son contraire moi j'insiste est
pas pour eux
le medef mais parce que j'allais animer
un une convention au meeting du medef ya
un peu plus d'un an ou manuel valls est
venu dire je vous aime aux entrepreneurs
pas moi aux entrepreneurs et je voyais
les entrepreneurs à côté de moi se lever
et applaudir wave asie manuel je me
disais dans m'attendais donc allemands
donnaient donc ils croient quand même
pas les promesses et peut alors sur le
coup valls a créé macron macro est venu
dire vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir je vais libéraliser les entreprises
je vais franchir les seuils sociaux je
vais remettre en cause des 35 heures
on va voir ce qu'on peut faire sur
l'investissement sur la participation
dans les entreprises sur les contrats
sauf que sauf que macro est bien gentil
mais à des frondeurs à l'assemblée
nationale
et comme les frondeurs disent à peu
peuple ligne jaune
en réalité on a un gouvernement
genius il ya une faille avec valse
macron et tous qui disent il faut faire
de la croissance il faut faire de
l'entreprise et tout et on a un autre
côté plus tenu par le parti socialiste
qui dit ne touchez pas à l'orthodoxie
socialiste
le résultat c'est que la politique
économique est complètement asphyxiés on
n'a plus du tout de ligne on ne sait
plus s'il faut favoriser les entreprises
ne pas favoriser un produit les jeunes
s'en vont
dès qu'ils ont fait une grande école
université va il préfère aller à londres
et préfère aller au canada ils préfèrent
aller aux états unis ou en australie
pour faire carrière
c'est la première fois qu'on a un tel
départ rendez vous compte on en est à
avoir deux fois et demie plus de jeunes
sortis des grandes écoles et des
universités qui en 2015 quittent le pays
pour aller faire carrière à l'étranger
que l'on en avait en 2011
en quatre ans deux fois et demie plus
voilà le résultat
vous croyez sincèrement aujourd'hui
quand vous voyez autour de vous vous
avez envie vous vous avez envie de vous
dire si vous aviez 25 ans aujourd'hui
est ce que vous diriez on va faire
carrière dans ce pays
on y croit on a envie on a des
gouvernants de qualité on a des
gouvernants crédible qui font en sorte
qu'on ait envie
ben voilà le principal reproche à la
gauche au delà de son amateurisme sur
tous les sujets
au-delà de ces échecs économiques au
delà ces échecs sociaux c'est de
décourager le pays
on a découragé les jeunes on vous a
découragé on a remis en cause l'identité
nationale un coup on naturalise à tour
de bras
un coup on ne sait pas ce qu'est la
politique migratoire un coup on nous
explique que le droit d'asile
il faut le restreindre l'emmenant au
louvre un qu'on vous annonce par madame
hidalgo qu'elle veut un centre de
migrants à paris un coup on a un
ministre de l'intérieur qui dit vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir
et on ne voit rien venir tout simplement
parce qu'il n'ya plus de ligne politique
on navigue au fur et à mesure des
sondages et on navigue de plus en plus
mal le chômage s'accroît les entreprises
n'y croit plus il ya plus
d'investisseurs étrangers en france
il préfère aller en allemagne
royaume uni ou en espagne parce qu'ils
ne croient plus dans la france le vrai
sujet le vrai problème
la vraie alternative pour 2017
c'est évidemment est ce que oui ou non
on va rendre aux français la république
est ce que oui ou non on va rendre aux
français la france qui est la leur celle
en laquelle il croit parce qu'ils sont
prêts à faire des sacrifices
ils sont prêts à travailler ils sont
prêts à défendre et l'économie et leurs
convictions et leur identité la nation
ils sont prêts à défendre la république
ça n'est pas vrai que tous les français
regardent vers les extrêmes mais encore
faut-il leur redonner de l'espoir
encore faut-il leur donner envie oui les
français sont presse bat pour la france
à condition d'avoir des gouvernants qui
ne soient pas des gouvernants de
rencontre à condition d'avoir des
gouvernants qui leur redonne envie
espoirs ambitions les français sont
fiers de la france
ils ne sont pas fiers de la manière dont
ils sont gouvernés voilà la réalité et
la république
elles méritent autre chose elles
méritent autre chose que ce que nous
subissons
franchement quand quand on voit ce qui
se passe quand on voit les efforts que
réalisent les pays voisins parfois
denses des crise plus profonde que la
nôtre oui il ya de quoi se dire mais
c'est pas possible
quand je vois moi au sénat chaque fois
qu'on se bat à chaque fois qu on a
l'impression d'avancer
on a le gouvernement qui revient en
arrière c'est pas possible il faut faire
plaisir aux frondeurs il faut faire
prendre le plaisir à la motion a baissé
du parti socialiste ah c'est pas
possible rendez pas compte on perdrait
les écologistes quelle perte
enfin mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand j'entends madame duflot
l'inestimable m duflot quand j'entends
madame duflot dire à françois hollande
vous nous avez conduit un waterloo moral
rendez compte
et comparé volant d'un napoléon
j'avoue moi je serai là polluants je le
relèverai du cercueil pour dire du don
ça va pas exagérer mais elle était
ministre de monsieur hollande vous
rendez compte des gens qui ont été
ministres deux ans qui viennent dire oui
le celui qui est président la république
nous conduit à waterloo
mais qui peut croire dans ce
gouvernement
et le problème c'est qu'il faut
aujourd'hui se remobiliser alors oui
vous êtes là nombreux oui nicolas
sarkozy va tout à l'heure vous vous dire
comment il voit la suite parce que il
nous faut une suite voilà parce que ce
pays ne peut pas en reste et se
cantonner à un pouvoir qui nous réduit
qui nous humilie qui fait en sorte qu'on
se dise c'est pas possible c'est pas
notre france c'est pas celle pour
laquelle on s'est battus c'est pas de
celle pour laquelle vous vous engagez
publiquement politiquement aujourd'hui
ce pays mérite le mieux et ce pays vous
mérite vous et vous vous méritez la
république et vous méritez un pays qui
aille différemment
vous avez envie d'être fiers de votre
pays vous avez envie d'être fiers de la
république vous avez envie d'être fiers
d'appartenir à la nation française quels
que soient vos origines et vous en avez
assez assez de voir que l'on réduit
cette république que l'on humilie ce
pays que l'on nous met dans une
situation où en réalité on se dit
pourquoi défendre la france aujourd'hui
avec des gouvernants de rencontrer des
gouvernantes circonstances alors oui les
républicains oui les républicains quand
je pense qu'ils nous ont fait un procès
les républicains il s'appelle bien les
socialistes mais enfin bon on leur
laisse mais les républicains
oui les républicains parce que dans le
fond on a choisi la thématique qui nous
apparaissait la plus discrédité la plus
mise en cause par ce gouvernement
et c'est la république quel plus beau
mot en france que la république celle
qui depuis 130 ans fait en sorte que
chacun soit à sa place celle qui fait
que depuis 130 ans l'ascenseur
fonctionne
les gens se reconnaissent celle qui fait
que depuis 130
quand on est dans la république quand on
respecte les lois de la république
quand on respecte les droits et les
devoirs de la république on se sent chez
soi
oui il n'y a pas de honte à dire que
quand on est français on croit dans la
nation on croit dans le drapeau on croit
dans la république
on croit dans la france et on croit dans
l'avenir et vous êtes là ce matin avec
nicolas sarkozy pour dire oui à l'avenir